so there's a couple of Star Trek rumors
knocking around a hard reboot of beloved
characters and a new series that
actually sounds pretty cool
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so first of all I am going to say yes
these rumors are from giant freaking
robot now we all know about giant
freaking robot they clickbait they
release stories that are just not true
and they regularly take credit for other
people's hard work but sometimes they
get the story right and I'm actually
hoping that one of the Articles at least
that they've released in the last couple
of days is true and the other one I
really hope isn't but why do I actually
think we should listen to John freaking
robot ever well actually Sidetrack
started because of a story on giant
freaking robot they released a story
saying that Stargate was going to have a
live-action series the series that then
a little later Brad Wright started to
write and an animated series to go along
with it I actually did a video on that
story and it got over a hundred thousand
views it did very well so from that
video I got a comment from a guy that
actually works in La he told me it's not
true anymore when the chief executive
change for MGM they scrapped the whole
animation studio idea but about a year
earlier than the Story released on giant
freaking robot they were actually
considering a live-action series with an
animated series so kind of True by giant
freaking robot just very very late and
from that conversation I developed a
network of sources that have been
serving the channel very very well ever
since so no that's no reason to actually
trust Joe freaking robot but it is proof
that that sometimes they get it right so
what are the rumors they've been talking
about in the last few days well the
first one is a seven of nine spin-off
series is apparently in pre-production
now that would actually be pretty cool
I'm assuming from what we've seen about
Picard Series 3 so far that 709 would be
the commander of the Titan and maybe
that series would be based aboard the
Titan any series of Jerry Ryan I'm
watching I love her and anybody that
says um that she's not the most gorgeous
creature to ever live is a liar and
wrong
um my wife watches this I'd love to see
a series in that time frame you know a
little after the Next Generation I don't
like the Titan ship I think it is ugly
as hell but you know I'm still a new
starship in that time
captained by seven of nine yeah I'd
watch the crap out of that and there has
always been rumors that Picard would be
replaced by another series
um section 31 has kind of gone quiet
with Michelle yo I'd still love to see
that as well but if those projects are
being scrapped and it's being replaced
to this seven of nine idea then yeah I'm
on board with it oh I'll watch the hell
out of that if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
there's merchandise available at
sidestrek.com or below on the video and
if you really enjoy the content consider
hitting that join button because that
really helps support the channel
brought to you the rumor the rumor that
I'm not so keen on
this one better be rubbish
so as we know from reports a few months
ago we are getting a Star Trek 4 from JJ
Abrams
whether we like it or not now even
though the director's now gone and the
script was actually written by those
guys now doing rings of power this film
is apparently still going to be in
cinemas roughly the end of next year but
according to this leak from giant
freaking robot from their trusted
sources
some of the characters in this movie are
actually going to be rebooted versions
of characters from The Next Generation
so we're going to see a younger Captain
Picard Geordie the forge Will Riker and
Wharf blah blah blah blah blah
um oh maybe Will Wheaton can come back
let's not do that now my first question
was what a bloody how's that going to
work
there's 130 years between the Enterprise
a and the Enterprise d
so tell me why in the episode we're
looking at it's going to be a time
rewind episode now we've not seen that
in the JJ Abram Star Treks yet so it's
about time really so okay there's going
to be time travel involved if you're
going to get in the comments now and say
they wouldn't do this of course it
wouldn't why would they hard reboot the
Next Generation well they've hard
rebooted Star Trek already we're on our
third Kirk we're in our third Spock
where we're going to get our third bone
soon
um we're on our
third of her they've already rebooted
all of these characters
I hate the new Kirk by the way it's such
a it's such a Wheezy looking man but
so we're already rebooting all these
characters Star Trek and Paramount
Pictures would of course reboot the Next
Generation characters and following on
from the big hurray the original actors
are getting in Picard series three I
could kind of understand them doing this
but I don't want them to
so next question apparently this would
then lead into and be a sort of a back
door reboot into then a series of next
Generation movies
so what timeline are they going to be in
so they're going to be in the Kelvin
timeline
now that's one way again of getting rid
of the whole reboot issue
um you know we're not going to see
stores you've seen before because it's a
different timeline it'd be interested
actually though just thinking off top of
my head it would actually be interesting
to see where the Federation ends up
in another 100 years
oh God am I starting to think this is a
good idea
oh wow okay
um but we would see the Federation and
it would be in the Calvin timeline we
can assume
um
are the Next Generation characters big
enough to though then create a series of
movies
I think so I think Picard is being a
complete failure to date but I'm really
hopeful for the third series that might
be a good springboard into this the TNG
characters now are older for the series
is all love that it has become sort of a
modern classic
so yeah I think these characters are
well known enough that they could
support a series of movies I don't think
we're going to see any more Star Treks
I'm really surprised we're going to Star
Trek four if I'm honest
from these characters the actors are
just too busy too big and you know um I
really think it's going to be very hard
to make any more of these films
but I could see then a whole new cast
making further Star Trek Kelvin timeline
movies
my last question is do I want this to
happen
no
I think it'll be bad I don't want to
sound like those people that complained
when the next Generation got rebooted
now these guys replace these characters
blah blah blah blah I just don't want to
do that
I I didn't like Discovery I didn't like
it when they rebooted the Enterprise and
had a new
um Captain Pike but I was proof wrong
because he's brilliant
so I don't really want my immediate
emotional response to sort of like put
my shutters down on this one because
look they did a great job of strange new
worlds it was brilliant
it's the best Star Trek we've had in
years so I cannot say that look it's
impossible for them to make something
good
I think it's just very unlikely the JJ
Abrams movies have not been good and
they're not good Star Trek
um they're quite entertaining quite
funny very action-packed movies but
they're not really good Star Trek
so
my confidence in Bad Robot being able to
make a good Star Trek the Next
Generation movie is really low
you know how hard it is for a filmmaker
to make Benedict Cumberbatch look like a
bad actor
that takes some real skill
but I'll still go and watch it because
I'm attracting that's what trekkies do
but hey get in the comments guys tell me
what you think is your immediate
reaction is giant freaking robot giant
freaking Liars like like I did or do you
actually think this story has half a
chance to have legs Could It Be A Way
forwards and actually would it be
interesting to see where the Federation
ends up in the Kelvin timeline a century
further on
maybe if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out also
consider if you enjoy the content it's
in the join button because that really
supports the channel as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]